a year ago i paid 120 000 for four hours
of one-on-one coaching with grant
cardone and in this video i'm going to
break down the major lessons and bullets
that i took away from the second call
that i had with him and if you don't
know who i am my name is alex romozy i
own acquisition.com i'm a business
investor and we own six portfolio
companies that do about 85 million a
year and i have nothing to sell you and
in the last 12 months i sold a majority
share of three companies two of which
for an enterprise value 46 million
dollars and the other one is
non-disclosed uh i'm not allowed to
disclose it so it was uh it had done 12
million in the last uh 12 months so it
was not a small business like i said i
want to break down the things that i
learned from grant and so before i dive
into that there's one kind of
overarching um shtick that i want to hit
on and it was because i posted a podcast
uh with grant that was actually not the
coach you call the coach call um for
some reason it didn't record so all i
have for the notes which is still cool
because it gave me some time to process
it i saw like a lot of hate in the
comments towards brandt and i wanted to
kind of address some thoughts that i had
around it so the first of these things
is that there was a lot of people were
like alex don't associate with this guy
your brand's so much better than that
and like oh this guy's a scammer i lost
all respect for you blah blah blah right
and first off i make these videos for me
so all good second off i think that
there were for those of you who had this
and the only reason i'm addressing this
is because i i genuinely want to help
because i don't think the mindset serves
you if you see someone go from zero to a
billion in a decade there are things
they did well and in that you can learn
of them whenever i look at anyone i
think that you can either try and throw
stones at them right or you can throw
stones of your ego and take out a pencil
and a pen and become curious and turn
envy into into interest into inquiry
right which is what are they doing
differently to me because if anyone
who's watching this or anyone who
commented 10 years ago you were alive
and you're an adult and 10 years later
right now you're not a billionaire he
did something better than you and if
you're not learning from that then i
think that you're missing a massive
opportunity um and this is in no way
saying grant is but there are horrible
people and i actually think grant has
pretty solid ethics and for those people
who don't feel that way that's fine you
don't know him you probably never met
him in person but i can tell you that of
every of the interactions that i've had
with him they've been positive he's been
respectful he's been attentive he's
cared um he's shown genuine interest in
in helping you know other people succeed
you guys got to get it like when you're
a billionaire right or at a billion and
or even once you cross 100 million your
need for money goes down to basically
nothing the marginal utility of it goes
down very very low in all the
conversations that have i've had with
him you need something that's going to
drive you and i genuinely believe and
maybe he's a master persuader but i i
genuinely believe that his intention is
to help as many people become
financially free i really i really do
think that so that's that's where i see
it from where i sit i could be wrong but
that is the perspective that i have okay
in the last call that i had with him i
talked about kind of four general things
one was wealth one was business kind of
opportunity the third was kind of real
estate and the fourth was kind of
personal brand and promotion we didn't
get to talk a lot about personal brand
and promotion on the first call and so
on this call i was like i just want to
focus on this thing and so the vast
majority of the bullets that i have for
you guys today are just about that topic
if you don't like if you can't
appreciate how good a grant is at
promotion probably just stop now so now
that that is covered i have probably
about 16 bullets that i wrote down as my
kind of consolidated takeaways and i'm
just going to kind of hit them one by
one some of them be short some of them
i'll include a little bit of commentary
but i think we'll have some fun all
right cool so the first thing that grant
said that i thought was kind of
interesting is i was like take on haters
he was like just be louder than them
he's like at the end of the day he's
like they're just talking about you and
one of the things that i took away from
this is that he said i'm not trying to
be liked he said i'm trying to be known
and what's interesting about that it's
so subtle but it's a very important
nuance from a perspective standpoint
that if you make your intention to be
known then all of a sudden your ego and
your feelings around what people say
diminish he's like he sees haters he's
like oh good they're talking about me
cool right and i think that he's proven
with his brand that he's been able to
continually grow despite anyone who's
been trying to stop him and so i think
that part of that is from that
perspective shift of his goal is not to
be liked his goal is to be known and he
said haters just flow more attention to
me they're talking about me and then
they bring me other people who do like
me and i thought that was a really
interesting perspective i thought there
was one that was really worth sharing
with you guys the next one was he saw
the role of the ceo as uh promote as his
first uh first objective the second was
promote and the third was promote and i
thought that was kind of interesting
because i had a conversation with grant
about my book right this guy and i told
him that we sold 100 000 copies in the
first six months and he was like well
you must have some crazy promotion i was
like i didn't it was just uh it's just
word of mouth he's like dude no one's
selling that kind of those kind of books
and those kind of volumes from word of
mouth i mean that is how they got sold
and so the thought the thing that was
interesting to me about that was that
this is this was my this is my
interpretation was that if you ask 20
billionaires right what the secrets are
they will typically tell you what their
superpower is right you'll talk to
someone they're like it's all about who
you know other people be like you gotta
know how to raise money other people be
like you gotta know how to sell you
gotta know how to whatever right and so
i think that it speaks more to
what type of entrepreneur you are in
terms of the vehicle that you use to
become successful so if you were to ask
elon his big thing now grant would argue
that elon's a master promoter and i
think he is but he also talks
exclusively about product um he's like
the only reason for businesses to exist
is because they have a superior product
if you listen to like warren and charlie
munger warren buffett and truly monger
they don't talk about promotion at all
they talk about the next customer is
sitting on the work on your desk that
you do well in front of you if you do a
good job the next customer will come and
so there are different ways to skin the
cat of success and for me that was kind
of my big takeaway now obviously
promotion is very important how grant
does everything with his crowdfunding
and whatnot and you can make the
argument that the amount of word of
mouth that we had from this was all the
promotion but the thing that gets you
that type of promotion is the product
not an actual kind of media or marketing
campaign so i thought that that was just
a really interesting tip that i would
share with you guys the next one was
when he talked about his transition for
me and part of the reason you guys i i i
sought out grant was because he's he
followed a path that is very unique and
eerily similar to the one that i have
i've kind of been on and i'll explain it
to you why i'm saying this so first he
was um a car salesman he was doing the
doing and then he taught people how to
sell cars and then he moved up to just
teaching sales and then he moved up from
there to talk about marketing which is
like a brief one-year stint and then
from there he switched to talking all
about real estate and that was kind of
his transition over time and i asked him
about what that transition looked like
and so first off he said like the bigger
the bigger the pool the better he said
every time i've leveled up and gone
wider everyone told me that it was a
stupid idea and i should stay in my
niche and they wanted to keep me small
and i you know every time i did it i
like 10x right i thought that was a nice
and interesting lesson but i do think
that the right lesson should be taken
from it which is he earned each of those
advancements i think i mean you can you
can try and skip to the top but i i
think most people don't have the depth
of knowledge and expertise to stand
there toe-to-toe with the other guys who
have earned their place there that's
just my perspective i do think that some
of these steps are requisite to getting
to the next level so that's you know my
two cents like if i were to stand here
and talk about these business things
that we do and i had no experience it
just it just wouldn't hit the same right
and i don't think i could deliver the
same way because i wouldn't have the the
depth of experience in terms of like my
belief in what i am saying my conviction
could not be there unless i was a
sociopath or like or less i'm just like
comfortable stating things that i have
no proof for right and so i do think
that there's a sequence to this so that
being said he said that each of those
transitions was a very deliberate
transition and he talked about the two
biggest ones for him the first one was
rebranding from uh sales to marketing so
there was a period of time when he got
in this thing with uh belford like the
the video went like super viral uh he's
the wolf of wall street that's jordan
ralph and they did this podcast together
and they're like kind of at each other's
throats but he told me that his
intention there was to was to purposely
rebrand and break away
from
sales being what he was associated with
and that's why he was like oh man sales
doesn't matter he's like marketing
matters it's all about marketing i think
that part of the reason that grant did
explode is i think that internally he
really did make that shift where he he
realized that marketing was just
sales on steroids right it's it's a
projection it's promotion i mean
marketing is sales at scale right and so
um but i do think that what makes you a
good marketer is being in good sales and
you have to understand it's all one
person before you can sell the masses
right and sell different types of people
one-on-one before you know how to talk
to the masses and so i thought that was
an interesting lesson and and kind of
tidbit that i took away from that and uh
and one of the key points about this and
this is the last thing that hit on and i
think this is really big so so pay
attention to this piece is that he said
each of those transitions he said people
aren't going to like remember like you
know paragraphs and paragraphs about
he's like they're just gonna have like
some sort of key association with you
right he's like they're gonna think okay
here's this guy this is his deal right
so he's like grant was sales he's like
and then i wanted them to think grant
was marketing so i didn't talk about
sales just marketing market market
marketing right he's like then he was
able to make the transition the jump
from marketing to real estate right he's
like so i want what people think red
cardone they think real estate that's
what he's like that's what i want them
to think when they think of me as real
estate
and he's like so for you and he's
talking to me he was like you need to
figure out what you want to be known for
and now mind you what we're talking
about now is not direct response this is
pure brand right and i would say this is
that a lot of the guys that i know who
have kind of been in the game a long
time is that a lot of us start in the
direct response world and then kind of
end up in the branding world and i think
it's because what happens is you extend
your time horizon and you realize that
branding actually has higher roi it just
takes way longer and that's the thing is
in the beginning you need the fast cash
but it kind of makes your brain a little
icky but as you kind of if you can
extend the time price a lot of times
branding will ultimately yield you the
highest return there's a reason that
chanel and louis vuitton and you know a
lot of these different types of brands
uh they're these strong brands that
exist and they don't do direct response
it's just about the brand and so i just
think that was just a really interesting
um takeaway now for us if you're curious
um i'm still debating what kind of that
sound bite but right now it's just
business investor like if people think
about me and they're like i want them to
think business but i also want them to
think investing so it's kind of like
those two things together because like i
came from this world of actually
building businesses but i've had to
learn more of the investing side as i've
gotten better now i know people came
from the investing side and have to
learn more about business so they invest
in best investment they realize they can
get better and better returns by
learning more and more about the game of
business and value creation etc whereas
like i was 100 in the in the value
creation game of business and had to
come towards the investing side and
really starting to see my business as an
investment starting to see capital
allocation and things like that as we
scaled and so i think that kind of the
perfect middle ground is you you
understand both worlds and so for me
that is uh my my best my best best bad
guess that i've got right now is just
what people think about me it's business
investors you probably hear me introduce
myself that way now it's like hey alex
rosie i'm a business investor and i own
acquisition.com portfolio companies et
cetera i think what's also useful is to
observe not just what um people say but
also what they're doing um and that was
just like a note that i wrote down to
myself it's like even when you're
looking at what i'm like to the best of
our ability i think we try and
communicate what we're thinking but
sometimes we innately do things without
even thinking that we're doing them and
so i think it's worth looking at both of
those things not just what someone's
saying the next one that i had was
meeting a big goal and so this was
actually a belief that he broke for me
on my first call because i was like i
just want i'm trying to just get to 10
million a month because that was like
the next goal was eight figures a month
so we're not there just transparency to
do the math we're about 7 million a
month i think i did this last month at
least 7.9 but like roughly 7 million a
month slowly growing hopefully we'll
we'll crack the nine figs this year but
we will see i'm patient but he's like
you need a bigger goal right and so he's
like why not 100 million a month and so
what ended up happening is actually
redesigned the entire acquisition.com
model to enable us to get there and it
was simply because i had somebody look
at me in the eyes and be like 10 million
a month well not 100 a month and it was
just incredibly impactful for me i just
it's so silly but he also always
explained that for him you know
originally it was a billion under
management he was like well shoot now
he's like now it's 50 billion i want 50
billion under management and so for me i
thought that was just like it's just
constantly kind of pushing and expanding
and he said this thing he said the more
i do the more i realize i can do and i
think that that is one of those beliefs
and things that like people say but like
if you can really internalize that like
i'm telling you i've met all like a lot
of people at the top of the game and
like they're no different than you know
like they're made of flesh they're made
of bones like they're just people and
they just believe they can because
there's like there's no rules like why
not and so i just want to encourage you
with that if uh if that helps somebody
the next one was he did acknowledge that
starting back at zero for undercover
billionaire was one of the hardest
things he ever did and i thought that
was interesting because right now i'm in
this uh interesting position where we we
exited three companies last year uh we
sold majority stakes in three companies
rather last year i sold my house i sold
two cars i saw i really liquidated a lot
of assets last year and starting
acquisition.com the core because before
this was more of a passive portfolio and
what acquisition.com now is is an active
investment portfolio so like it's a
business of building businesses through
investment and and all the stuff that we
do which i won't even get into it what's
unique about the position now that i'm
in is that i'm remembering how little
leverage you have when you start out
right like i'm building just like the
core team of like 12 people and that's
just like just to feel like i can get
get things going and so it reminded me
of when i've started the other
businesses that i've had like what it's
like to do it because i've been so far
above the businesses for such a long
time that it was a really good reminder
for me and i'll tell you the one big
difference that's happened this time for
me versus times in the past is that this
time i have had i've kind of seen the
mountaintop in terms of the level of
boredom and the and the kind of the
meaninglessness of just just having all
these companies that just pound out cash
flow to you and just wondering what the
point of it all is and getting back into
the trenches and getting back into the
grind right now it's like i can't it's
hard to articulate but like i'm just
incredibly grateful for it like i'm back
in it i can i can see all the things
that have to get done
and it's just before this i was so much
more stressed because i was always
worried about all this stuff but like
this time like i know it's gonna work
out it's fine and i'm just enjoying the
fact that i get to work again and uh
there was a long period of time where i
feel like i couldn't work because
there's nothing i could do because the
businesses were running and if i were to
try and jump in i would have broken
something because i would be doing
someone else's job and so it's cool to
have work again i'm only sharing this
because like it doesn't matter like what
season you're in like if you are working
like we are meant to work it's been it's
been incredibly gratifying for me to to
get back in it so just wanted to share
that little tidbit with you okay another
one was that uh rich people sell and
wealthy people hold forever and so i
think that and the two caveats that he
provide here that i agree with that one
unless the party is over unless you
think the opportunity is going to long
term disappear or because they're no
longer you know have an interest or they
have an interest in doing something else
in the capital to better allocate
towards something right and that that
opportunity is better and so i would say
that for me i wanted to have a vehicle
that could compound cash flow that i
could actively manage for myself and so
that was why acquisition.com went from
being the side thing to the main thing
and that is the primary reason that we
that we sold the majority stakes in
three of those companies so that the
portfolio could be the one thing rather
than having like three of these
companies plus a portfolio it was too
much for me to manage headspace wise
just like emotional energy not
necessarily time wise and so
now that we have done it i am super
grateful and i'm very 100 sure it was
the right decision and i'm honestly
really grateful that i did make that
call because it was a very hard decision
for me to make and i'm just i made the
right call and i'm really happy about it
okay and so the reason that wealthy
people never sell is because when you
have an extended time horizon like all
assets go up in value unless they crash
in which case they become unsellable but
like for most of the things that you're
hopefully doing it's like if you have a
plan that you base on assumptions that
are that are reasonable they will
continue to grow and compound faster and
compound tax-free etc and what he was
saying was that he's like every single
building that i've sold i regret selling
because i would have made more if i just
kept it that's when i kind of had a
different understanding of debt and
refinancing and things like that that
i've covered in other videos that like
you can have you can you can have
liquidity based on the assets you have
without actually having a sale event
which is something that i didn't
understand until far too late so i've
talked about that another video so i'm
not going to dive into that okay so this
is kind of the next kind of breaking
point in terms of of topics that we
started covering so when we started
talking about uh you know kind of
building our our personal brand uh he
talked about how he had built his and
some of the specific things that he that
he focused on and the thing is is that
in the beginning what you do is you
attract people who are like you and so
it's like when you see the 25 year old
agency guru you know white guy and you
look at his customers it's a bunch of 25
year old white agencies right and so the
thing is is that independent of like you
could say whatever you want but people
trust people who look like them more and
so if if trust is a component of why
people buy or believe that a message is
for them then it would behoove us if we
want to scale our business to reach as
many of those people as possible which
means that you need multiple faces of
the business and so this is one of the
things that i actually we implement
within the portfolio companies which is
like getting them to transition from a
single face to multiple faces so that
like if you look at you know jenny craig
or whatever it's like it's not just one
white girl right it's like you've got a
black girl an asian girl and uh and a
mexican guy and whatever you know what i
mean like you've got you've got
different races and ages and
demographics represented because for
that sub demo they're going to resonate
with just the physical appearance of the
avatar and so i thought that was really
interesting and as a caveat on that he
also themed he's like you remember i had
like a different thing every day so it's
like we've got young hustlers and that's
for young people he's like we've got the
we had the marriage thing that was for
married people we had the elena does the
girls thing and so like each of these is
very strategically put in place to cover
and hit a different demographic which i
thought was really obvious in retrospect
but just a really good reminder you know
what i mean i've said this before but we
need to be reminded more than we need to
be taught and so it just like brought it
back to top of mind for me and then he
talked about some of the things in terms
of topics that um that resonate with
people as wide broad categories so each
of these is kind of like these these
these silos right so first i'll talk
about the the demographics and the races
and the representatives then you've got
like the interests right of like uh like
the topics the topical interests and
then you have what are the kind of
general categories so it's like people
are interested in themselves he's like
they're interested in their families
they're interested in their in their sub
group he's like they're interested in
mankind they're interested in animals
which is why all these memes and tick
tock all animals right he's like they're
interested in the spiritual they're
interested in god and they're interested
in the physical universe which is like
the whole all the people love nature and
love hiking and love pictures of all
that green you know all that stuff right
he's like so when you're thinking about
how to hit as many people as possible
it's trying to weave in all these
different dynamics and i'll be candid
with you it's not like i'm gonna be able
to do all this stuff overnight which is
why it's taking him 10 12 years to get
to this point right but to me it was it
was actually just very
interesting it was a great it was a
great piece that i've now a great lens
through which to see the stuff that
we're putting out because he's like dude
you've got beard and the flannel on the
hat he's like you're just going to
attract a bunch of people look like you
and if you look at the demographics of
this channel it's like 96 dudes that are
like 25 to 45 right and so that's me and
so um not to say that anything that we
say here doesn't affect like woman-owned
businesses or businesses of guys who are
you know 60-plus it's just that they're
not going to necessarily see me and
think oh this content and this message
is for me so i thought that that was
really um eye-opening and in terms of
how he sees scaling that's how he sees
hitting wider and wider demographics so
i figured i would share that with you
now the next piece to this because after
he shared all this stuff i was like all
right well then what's what's your
framework what's the plan for how you
execute on all this stuff and he just
laughed dude he's like there's no plan
he was like he's like maybe he's trying
to tell you there's some framework or
something he's like they're just trying
to sell you [ __ ] he's like just 10x bro
and he said it kind of jokingly but he
meant it he was like we just do
everything and we just increase the
output he's like and then he pulled up
uh you know my instagram and he pulled
up his he's like look bro he's like
you've got one post he's like i got six
today he's like look at your twitter
he's like i've got you got two he's like
i got 10. he's like look at linkedin and
so he's just taking massive action on
every single channel and post and post
and post and post post and here's
something interesting because i was like
won't people get sick of like all that
stuff and this is a belief right and
some of you may think that whatever but
i'll share with you what he shared with
me which i thought again like i said
with the whole known thing at the very
beginning is a really interesting
paradigm shift his goal is not to be
loved his goal is to be known the next
things i'm going to share with you are
are really along that lines that i
thought were pretty good all right he's
like so first off my goal
is for people to acknowledge my
existence he's like we found from our
last event that 40 of sales came of the
highest level he said came from people
who had unsubscribed from my email list
most people get so upset about people
unsubscribing for their email list he's
like to me he's like i see that as
they're like oh i know who you are i
acknowledge you you exist i remember you
and so for him he's like dude he's like
we shoot to unsubscribe he's like we
wanna we wanna pound people so that they
know who we are he's like because we
think we're over communicating he's like
but we're not actually batting it
battling against competition he's like
our only competition is obscurity i was
like huh interesting it's just like it
was just a very interesting dynamic and
he said so the biggest competitor that
you have is whatever is trending right
now and so a lot of people talk about
trend hopping and things like that but
he he took it from a different
perspective which i thought was was was
useful which was the trend he sees as
the competitor who's eating the eyeballs
and the ears of the people that he wants
to reach he's like they're hearing all
of this stuff about these trends and
whatever the macro thing and the hot you
know whatever news is he's like so
that's why i make videos to attack that
thing that competitor which is whatever
the hot news is so he sees it as
attacking that that trans different way
of seeing kind of hopping on trends and
whatnot and so then finally in terms of
thought process around this he's like
listen 10x assume no one will see it so
that you don't judge yourself on it and
remember that the goal is to be known
rather than to be loved and he achieves
polarity through authenticity and that
was one of the sound bites that i that i
took for myself was polarity i don't
know if you said that or this is just
from my notes but polarity through
authenticity which is like if you are
just a hundred percent you're just gonna
have people who hate you and think about
this this is one this is just from alex
but you should want to be hated by some
people like if hitler existed you'd hope
he hates you right that's you know what
i mean like that you like the goal can't
be to be loved by people because you
probably don't love everyone and the
people that you really don't like would
you really want them to like you because
it would mean that you have similar
values to them and so you can't do that
right it's like it's it's an
impossibility it's an irrational
impossibility and so just by just being
who you are and just sharing the values
that you have will inherently attract
the people who share those values and
repel the people who don't and those
people who repel if done properly right
will tell other people about how much
they hate you and then more people know
who you are right and then they will end
up bringing people who will share those
values with you because have you ever
heard somebody talk [ __ ] about somebody
and heard everything they said and
they're like well i kind of agree with
what this other guy you know with what
the other guy was saying in the story
and then all of a sudden you go and find
that person or go look them up or
whatever and you're like oh this guy's
pretty legit right and so um i found
that as a very interesting uh caveat
just like just again as mental
frameworks because this is this might be
valuable for you if you were to have
heard and i wish i had been able to
record it for some reason it didn't save
right if you heard the conversation it
wasn't like i was asking like hey how do
you run this ad hey can you look at my
ad copy like hey can you whatever like
at this at this point at least for me
what i'm looking for is is frameworks
through rich to see the world lenses
that can shift perspective because the
most difficult thing the most
constraining thing you know if you've
been following my channel there's three
things that limit us right it's our
skills it's our character traits and our
beliefs and we have deficiencies in each
of these and the difficulty is knowing
which one is the biggest deficit at this
particular moment in my opinion the
hardest one is beliefs because my
favorite quote from orson scott hart is
uh we question all of our beliefs except
for those that we truly believe and
those who never think to question
because if you really believe something
you never think to question it right
it's only the only the beliefs that you
believe half-heartedly because then
you're you're easy it's easy to question
those because you don't really believe
them or you sort of believe them but the
things that are deeply ingrained you
make these statements as though they
were truth and they're just false and
that's what's so hard because you base
all your assumptions and you you base
your vision and your future on this
foundation that's not real so for me
that's what i look for when i'm trying
to find people who are ahead of me and
so that's why at the very beginning of
this i was saying i think a lot of
people miss out on the opportunity when
you see people who are doing better
within you at the game provided they're
doing they're not doing anything illegal
so just as a side note for everybody
when people say is so-and-so legit
legitimacy comes from legitimacy which
is latin which means legal or lawful lex
is a latin for law and so what it means
is like if someone says this guy isn't
legit what you're saying is what he's
doing is illegal maybe you won't say
that because maybe that's not what you
mean and if that's not what you mean
then use better words that being said as
long as the person is not doing
something that is unlawful right and you
can look at that like what are the laws
like make sure that what you're what
someone is doing is lawful and they are
doing better than you at the game of
business and making more money it means
that they are doing something better
than you and so if you look at these
people rather than having this casting
stones mentality if they're doing better
than you it's like i think it's more
valuable to say like huh in what ways
are they better than me let me examine
that and then it gives you some
perspective to analyze yourself and say
in this way i want to improve and then
you can and then you can see it and
honestly i've got all of the biggest
breakthroughs that i've had been have
been from having conversations like i
had with grant like i've had so i always
try and pay as much as i possibly can to
have access to people and it's not
really like the sound bites that i
shared with you were all great but the
things that i'm really looking for are
the how are they seeing the world what
what false belief can i identify that
i'm basing my future on that it's not
true and that's ultimately i think the
biggest benefit of having people who are
further ahead than you is that they see
what you do not see and that's i mean
fundamentally like at least how i see
wisdom is that two people can look at
the same scenario somebody who's wise
and someone is unwise someone who's
unwise when we see one or two outcomes
somebody who's wise sees a number of
outcomes that they can apply to the
given scenario so they see what other
people cannot see that being said i hope
this this video is valuable for you uh
and saved you you know 30 000 or 120 000
of coaching to just give you the uh the
nuggets that were valuable to me as a as
a little sign off for you my name is
alex ramose i'm a business investor i
own acquisition.com and i have nothing
to sell you so lots of love welcome to
mozy nation if you're new and i'll see
in the next video